Vsauce Kevin here with a homemade deck of 52 mean cards
to show you a game that should be perfectly fair,
but actually allows you to win most of the time. How,
because there's a hidden trick and a simple algorithm that if you know,
it makes you the overwhelming favorite,
even though it appears that both players have a perfectly equal 50,
50 chance to win well, that's not very fair.
What is fair?
We can consider a coin to be fair because it's binary.
It has just two out comes when you flip it heads or tails.
And each of those outcomes are equally probable,
although it could land on its edge
in 1993,
Daniel Murray and Scott teal posited that an American nickel, which has a flat,
smooth outside Ridge could theoretically land on its edge
about one in every 6,000 tosses. But for the most part,
since the first Electrum coins were tossed in the kingdom of Lydia in seventh
century,
BC goings have been pretty fair as are playing cards like
this deck of handcrafted meme cards. When you pull a card,
you either get a red or a black card,
Ryan Carson, it's perfectly binary,
and there's no way for a car to like land on its edge.
It's either red or it's black.
It's 50% like a snap from FENOs
given that.
Is it possible to crack the theoretical coin flipping code and take
advantage of a secret non transitive property within this
game? Yes. Welcome to the humble Nissiyama randomness game.
Walter penny debuted a simple coin flipping game in the October,
1969, issue of the journal of recreational mathematics and then Steve humble.
And you talk on Nissiyama made it even simpler by using playing cards.
Here's how it works.
The first player chooses a sequence of three possible outcomes from our deck of
cards like red, black, red,
and then the second player chooses their own sequence of three outcomes like
black, black, red. And then we just flip our red and black meme cards.
And the winner is the one whose sequence comes up first. So in this example,
thanks to guy Fieri player one would have won this game because player one
chose red, black, red.
Here's a little bit of a nitpick because we're not replacing the red and black
cards after each draw.
The probability won't be exactly 50 50 on every draw because
each time we've removed one colored card,
the odds of the opposite color coming next is slightly higher,
but it'll never be far from perfectly fair. And as we play it,
we'll continue to out.
So given that each turn of the card has a roughly equal chance of
being red or black.
And given that the likelihood of each sequence of three is
identical.
The probability that both players have an equal chance of winning what their red
and black sequences has to be 50 50 to
right wrong.
And to demonstrate why I've invited my best friend in the whole wide world.
Where are you? Best friend. Kiano Reed.
Okay. All right. Okay. I know you're a little tall. Hold on.
What's this?
Okay. Kiana will be player one.
There are only eight possible sequences that Kiano can choose. Red, red,
red, red, red, black, red, black, red, red, black, black, black, red, red,
black, red, black, black, black, red, or black, black, black,
no matter what Kiano chooses.
The probability of that sequence hitting is equal to all the other options for
player one. There really is no bad choice.
One choice is as good as the next.
So let's say that Kiano chooses black, red, black, great choice there.
Kiano. Now that I know your sequence, I'm going to choose black,
black, red. Okay.
Now we'll just draw some cards and see which sequence appears.
First red Tommy was so
some red flex seal action so far, nobody has an advantage.
Black, where are your fingers?
Oh, sad. Sad.
Kiano you should be sad once you realize that.
Now there's no way that I can lose because of having these
two black cards in a row. Even if I pull five more black cards in a row,
eventually I will get a red and I will win.
Or my GERD,
ah, there it is. Minecraft.
Steve has sealed the victory for me. Sorry,
my most excellent dude, but I win because regardless of what player,
one chooses,
what matters is the sequence that player two picks as player two.
The method here is very easy.
I just put the opposite of the middle color at the front of the line.
So when Kiano picked BRB,
I just changed his middle arm to a B,
and then put that at the front of my sequence.
So I just dropped the last letter and my sequence becomes B B R
I'll show you another example. If Kiana had chosen red, red,
then I would have just changed that middle R to a B,
put that at the beginning of my sequence dropped the last R and my sequence
would be B R R.
Just that little trick allows me to have an advantage anywhere from about two
to one, up to 7.5 to one,
which means in the worst possible scenario for me,
I win two out of three times.
And in the best it's nearly eight out of nine. Look,
I'll write out all the choice options and their odds as player two.
When we apply the algorithm,
we're jumping into exactly the right place in a cycle of outcomes.
That player one doesn't have any control over the best player one can
do is choose an option. That's the least bad.
How is this possible? How can I take something?
So seemingly fair to both players. So obviously.
50 50 And.
Turn it so strongly in my favor. The key is in recognizing that.
This game is non transitive.
So there you go. The end, wait.
What is transitive? Think of it this way. You've got a,
B and C a B to B and B, B, C, therefore,
a beats C, because if a beats B and BBC,
then obviously a can beat C that game is transitive.
So if you and your Kiano whoops had transitive food preferences,
you'd rather have pizza than tacos,
and you'd rather have tacos then dog food.
You'd also rather have pizza than dog food. Simple.
If you, in your Keanu,
somehow preferred dog food to pizza,
then all of a sudden your food preferences become non
transitive in a non transitive game.
There is no best choice for the first player because there's no super
powered a instead there's a loop of winning choices like
rock paper scissors in rock paper, scissors, rock,
which we'll call a loses to paper,
which we'll call B B is better than a,
but a beats scissors,
which is C so a is better than C,
but B loses to C.
So C is better than B and paper B beats rock a.
So B is better than a scissors.
C loses to rock a and beats paper B.
And we've got a loop of possible outcomes that goes on
forever with no one choice being stronger than the other.
That's non transitive. Since we're in the flow chart mood,
here's a flow chart that illustrates the player to winning moves in the humble
Nissiyama randomness game. So if you follow the arrows,
you can see that our beats BBB and like BBR
beats BRB, and so forth with the odds added,
you can clearly see how some sequence scenarios go from bed to
worse
in the humble Nissiyama randomness variation of pennies game.
We know what sequence of card colors player one has chosen first.
So we can jump in the most advantageous part of the non transitive loop
and make a choice that gives us a significant advantage.
By recognizing that the game is non transitive,
we can take seemingly obvious fairness and find a paradoxical
loophole that nearly guarantees us success to everyone who doesn't
recognize the intransitivity.
It just kind of looks like we're extremely lucky.
And why does all of this matter?
Because bacteria play rock paper scissors to multiply Benjamin Kirkup
and Margaret Riley found that bacteria compete with one another in a non
transitive way. They found that in mice intestines,
E coli bacteria formed a competitive cycle in which three
strains basically played a game of rock paper,
scissors to survive and find an equilibrium pennies game and
its variations illustrate how even a scenario that seems
perfectly straightforward,
like unmistakably simple should never be taken at
face value. There's always room to develop,
strategize and improve our odds.
If we put in the effort and imagination.
Wired to understanding the situation and that
truly is
breathtaking and as.
Always, thanks for watching.